what is the area of the triangle and  they're talking about this triangle here  and like always pause this video and see  if you can figure it out on your own  alright now let's work through it  together so we know that the area of a  triangle is going to be equal to 1/2  times our base times our height time we  do the height in a different color x  times our height so what is the length  of our base in this scenario well the  base is this 18 right over here  let me highlight it this this length  right over here is our base so the base  is 18 and what is the height well the  height we see is 6 they give it to us  they don't always give it to you but in  this example they do so the height is  the height the height is I'm having  trouble with my pen is 6 so now we just  have to compute what 1/2 times 18 times  6 is let's think about this a little bit  1/2 times 18 is 9 9 times 6 is equal to  what 9 times 6 is equal to 54 and we're  done this is 54 square units